[Aplausos]
les pregunto a ustedes
quien les dice que no pueden lograr lo
que ustedes quieren hacer y les dice que
no lo pueden intentar que no lo pueden
lograr porque estos son los mensajes que
estamos recibiendo a lo largo de nuestra
vida que no podemos dejar por todo el
mundo que no podemos estudiar o trabajar
que tenemos que terminar la carrera para
empezar a lograr nuestros sueños es lo
que nosotros estamos escuchando todos
los días lo más triste es que eso que
nos están diciendo empieza a permear en
nuestra cabeza y acabamos creyendo en
esos mensajes que acabamos dejando de
creer en nosotros mismos ahora somos
nosotros los que decimos no podemos
hacerlo no lo podemos lograr y no lo
vamos a intentar ahora qué pasaría si
les digo que eso lo pueden utilizar a la
inversa porque las palabras son muy
poderosas pero también no es la mente
qué pasaría si nosotros empezamos a
decir se lo vamos a hacer si lo vamos a
lograr si lo vamos a alcanzar y si lo
vamos a intentar y sabes que entre más
me dices que no lo puedo hacer más me
dan ganas de hacerlo y eso es lo que yo
he pensado toda la vida
porque a mis dos años les puedo decir 22
años no dos años enteros yo les puedo
decir que he cumplido muchas cosas que
la gente me decía que lo iba a cumplir
como yo tuviera 35
uno de mis autores favoritos se llama
gwynne dyer y dice actúa como si
cualquier cosa que desees ya estuviera
aquí
convéncete de que cuando buscas ya lo
has recibido y cuando lady esto dije
guau
no sé es totalmente cierto y es lo que
yo he hecho todos los días de mi vida
digo yo quiero ser editora de moda tenía
15 años en ello les informaba si está de
moda y obviamente se han inyectado nueva
serie de mapas como acaba de estudiar
cómo se prepara si tienes que prepararte
pero pues también se van a soñar e
intentarlo
entonces empecé con las cosas pequeñas
empecé conozco las pequeñas empecé a
decretar yo sabe toda esta filosofía y
empecé a decir yo quiero ser yo voy a
hacer yo seré porque cuando somos
chiquitos decimos súper fácil yo voy a
hacer doctor yo voy a hacer director de
cine yo voy a hacer actriz yo voy a
hacer cantante súper seguros preguntar a
cualquier niño pero díganme ustedes si
no conforme vamos creciendo empezamos a
decir yo quisiera pero las cosas
empiezan a surgir y como quien está es
tan segura y la vez las cosas negativas
y se hace un relajo en la cabeza
entonces como yo tengo que decirles yo
quiero yo voy a hacer y yo seré
empecemos con las cosas pequeñas porque
tus pensamientos en tu objetivo y
siempre hay que visualizarlo yo
visualice que quería ser editor de moda
y dije que voy a empezar con algo
pequeño voy a empezar con un blog empecé
a ver a cómo constan de moda los blogs y
si ellas pueden y también lo puedo hacer
abrí mi blog blogspot está bien chapita
pero para small lo que importa es lo que
escribía y escribía de verdad cosas que
me llegaban el corazón tal fue así que
muchas niñas empezaron a identificarse
con lo que escribía y ya no lo leían mis
papás lo lean y eso pasa y mejor amiga y
luego los de mi salón y logran más y más
y más personas que leían lo que escribía
hasta que un día llegó la persona que yo
quería que lo leyera inconscientemente
la traje no creo que estaba en prepa y
estaba en una clase de matemáticas y me
llegó un correo de seventeen
latinoamérica tiene 16 años
la revista que yo leía en chapa o
sentencia no compuesto o sea no los voy
a creer y en la siguiente tarde yo
estaba sentada con la directora
editorial de ese evento y latinoamérica
porque querían trabajar conmigo
entonces casi cómo iba a cumplir 17 yo
escribía yo ya escribía para la revista
seventeen la cual yo leía entonces yo le
usa mis amigas me siempre sé cómo lo
hiciste
porque igual y también hay muchas que
quieren lo mismo que yo pero el chiste
es ponerse a trabajar y luchar por esos
sueños tampoco desde que solo decrete
sino que decrete es y lo hagas porque
conforme tú vas hablando en positivo y
en afirmativo yo lo voy a hacer yo yo
voy a hacer la editora yo voy a trabajar
para esta empresa yo voy a hacer
director de cine cinematógrafo el mejor
de la industria actriz empieza a creer
lo que estás diciendo y empieza a creer
que es posible no que es imposible y es
el chiste la fuerza que te va a dar para
dar el primer paso el primer paso es un
pequeño pequeño paso abrir un blog o no
sé lo que ustedes quieran piensen lo que
quieren lograr y cuál sería ese pequeño
paso porque ustedes ponen sus propios
límites y ese pequeño paso ustedes saben
cuál es dependiendo de lo que quieran
lograr y lo pueden hacer ahorita mañana
en cinco minutos saliendo de la plática
no tienen que esperar que acaba en la
carrera a que tengan un título saben o
sea lo pueden hacer ahorita y lo padre y
lo hermoso y lo increíble de las redes
sociales es que nos tocó una bonita
época en la cual nos puede servir de
herramienta y de apoyo para lograr esas
cosas para crear para tener una voz para
que la gente nos escuche
porque yo sé que todos nosotros tenemos
algo que decir
aunque tú no seas influencer y tengan
seguidores tú ya eres un influenciar con
la gente que te rodea porque tú le
aportas algo a cada persona y tienes una
voz y es lo para de las redes sociales
también te pueden ayudar para cumplir
esos sueños
aquí está el blog de fer altos en la
revista seventeen así me pusieron en las
páginas mi primer post fue 10 tips para
alcanzar tus sueños porque de veras yo
tenía ese trip que dije es que esto
funciona es que yo me vi es que yo traje
eso que pensé es verdad yo creo
muchísimo y la energía van a decir está
loca y así así así es muy típico que
digan eso pero creo que sí a través
mucho lo que piensas igual y no crees en
el universo pero si tú a tú piensas
positivo al final eso vas a creer y
aunque el principio diga así es difícil
conseguir conforme más lo dices vas a
decir que igual y si igual y si entonces
empieza a trabajar por tus sueños
después empecé con otro pequeño paso y
quise ser conductora de televisión
aunque me encantaba me encanta hablar me
encanta a mí el arte en general la
actuación el cine el teatro me fascina y
dije vamos a empezar con las grandes
ligas no y entretainment eso es decir un
canal que creo que iba mucho a 5 lo que
me gustaba en estilo de vida viajes y
surgió un casting que se llamaba chica y
2015 en el cual niñas de toda la
república mexicana iban a concursar para
hacer conductora de esa cadena esto yo
no me acuerdo que les dije a mis papás
que iba a ir al casting y menciano
no te preocupes toda la seguridad está
en algún punto todos somos humanos y
están a llegar juntos a no soy tan
bonita no soy tan alta como una con
dudas conductores de televisión no no
soy tan bueno no tengo experiencia en
fin un día antes del concurso de la
noche dije si voy a ir si voy a ir no me
importa me puse mis jeans me fui a las 6
de la mañana y estaba parada en el pepsi
center y empecé a ver todas las niñas
imagínate cuántas personas queriendo
tú ves a todos nos pasa porque no somos
los únicos que queremos algo hay mucha
gente que lo quiere pero cada uno de
nosotros tenemos algo diferente que
todos los demás la verdad es que si
somos únicos si tenemos algo diferente
entonces me empecé a concentrar porque
empecé a ver todas las chavas así que es
súper producidas y yo así como los niños
verdad no me arregle nada entonces me
puse mis audífonos empecé escuchar
música y empecé a visualizar me así en
el canal el programa conduciendo
conociendo gente súper talentosa grandes
productores está concentrar entonces
pensar en qué iba a decir hasta que
fueron muchas horas de espera y ya llegó
mi turno estaba para dar con el jurado
empezaron a hacer preguntas empezaron a
preguntarme qué habla en inglés que
antes era una entrevista ficticia en fin
resulta que quede en las 10
semifinalistas yo me lo podía creer me
fui a mi casa y les dije a mis papás no
quede para ver qué hacían no te
preocupes que si estaba bien difícil
yo creo que al día siguiente en la
mañana yo estaba en la regadera se los
juro voy a parecer una loca por estar
con los ojos cerrados así de hecho voy a
ser la próxima chica y yo voy a ser la
próxima chica y luego esté súper bien
pues están valorando mis sueños así yo
sí me está mentalizando es así funcional
y tal de life así con que pensarlo
decirlo en voz alta
sabes así empoderar t decir si lo voy a
hacer bien sucio me agrede seguridad
llegue al casting al día siguiente de
las 10 estuve en las seis el sexto en
las tres
y fue después todo un mes de pruebas el
cual nos hacían de todo y al final pues
me gané y estaba muy contenta porque
aparte dos años antes en eventos yo me
encontraba a las cámaras de y el
productor se llamaba güero y creo que yo
fui con el güero y le dije bueno cómo
estás yo soy fernanda y voy a ser
conductora de entertainment
entonces ese día cuando yo gané me
acerqué con el web le dije que aún
aguarda atacas de mí soy fernanda te vi
hace como dos años
sí lo sé
y fue el siguiente productor que de
hecho el primer programa en el que
estuve se llamaba life for me latino y
era en vivo se imagínense yo no sabía
conducir y luego me ponen un programa en
vivo sano no fue todo un reto pero dije
lo voy a hacer bien lo haga y ahora es
que sí o sea con la práctica se aprende
y con la experiencia se aprende
a veces mi carta de felicidad entonces
lo que yo les digo es que decretar o sea
es usar el poder de tu palabra para
obtener los resultados que deseas
ustedes empiecen a pensar qué es lo que
quieren hacer y dejen esos pensamientos
que la gente les dice que no lo van a
lograr que no lo pueden hacer que tienen
que esperar ellos que saben tú eres el
que te vas a encargar de lograr lo que
tú quieras hacer solo tú así que yo creo
que ustedes se pregunten qué quiero
hacer que necesito para lograrlo y lo
voy a lograr lo voy a hacer
o sea si quiero hacer un hotel-boutique
ahí en tu lumbre ve cómo va a ser
visualiza lo los pisos y tú velo porque
solo así vas a empezar tú como a entrar
en el mundo y empezar a atraer eso y
empezar a hacer cosas por lograrlo
porque estamos a sólo a un paso de
comenzar el camino para lograr nuestros
sueños y nosotros vamos a decidir cuándo
vamos a dar ese paso hoy mañana en un
año cinco años imagínense si cuatro no
hubiera dicho nombre no que es que en
cine se mueren de hambre en méxico si se
mueren de hambre no lo creo fueron un
dijo
eso no es cierto lo que la gente le dijo
no es verdad y yo lo voy a hacer hay
muchísimos ejemplos de gente imagínate
que nunca lo hubieran intentado que
nunca hubieran dado el paso
todos tenemos sueños y basta con
imaginar los y decretar los para sentir
que se pueden alcanzar y hacer realidad
ustedes los que se ponen sus límites
empiecen de verdad o sea yo digo
decreten piensen que es posible piensa
que la realidad ya está aquí y cuidado
que empiezan a decretar el mal en
negativo porque yo soy de la cancelado
cancelado cancelado tres veces toco
madera es verdad e igual así siempre en
positivo siempre afirmativo si lo voy a
hacer si lo voy a lograr y ustedes
mismos son sus propios límites en verdad
todo lo que ustedes quieran lo pueden
hacer aprovechen sus momentos aprovechen
sus sus días estudien trabajen harán
cosas pero hagan cosas den pasos y
luchen por lo que quieren hacer no
piensen que es imposible porque eso es
lo que está en su mente y si ustedes
empiezan a pensar que es posible empezar
a decir y empiezan a ver se lo van a
lograr yo estoy segura porque todos
podemos así que es una vida muy corta
como para estar pensando que no podemos
hacer lo que queremos hacer es una vida
tan corta que necesitamos lograr todos
nuestros sueños y cada minuto te debe
hacer algo que nos acerque a ellos se
queda el primer paso
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]